okay today I'm going to talk to you
about x-rays x-rays are part of the
electromagnetic spectrum that are found
between ultraviolet and gamma rays but
Cris they're part of the electromagnetic
spectrum
they're transverse waves that travel at
around 300 million meters per second
through a vacuum so we're going to have
a look at some of the uses of x-rays and
some of the dangers so the first thing
that I'm sure most of us are aware of or
use of x-rays of x-ray images so
essentially they can be used to detect
things like broken bones now we may know
that that's the use but how does that
actually work so let's imagine someone
goes into into hospital because they
think they might have broken their arm
so inside obviously wouldn't be able to
see this bone that's inside their arm
but this this bone might have a fracture
on it and we want to see if it's
fractured we want to be able to tell if
it's fractured so what happens is they
go to have it x-rayed so what happens
the reason why we can create an image
from this is we have this thing behind
the behind the arm or whatever part of
the body that were x-ray and we have
this thing called a detector plate and
the way that it works is x-rays are
emitted towards the arm now let's
imagine this off the tissue here which
is the skin x-rays can go directly
through the skin they can transmit
through the skin
however objects with a higher density
such as bones the x-rays are absorbed by
these they cannot be transmitted through
those harder surfaces so as a result on
the detector plate we get an image so
all of the the parts that have a higher
density such as bones actually show up
as white whereas the other tissues that
the x-rays can transmit through show up
is black so the detector plate creates
an image
so the radiographer can then give this
information to a doctor who could then
make a diagnosis about whether that bone
is broken or not so that's how x-ray
images works based on x-rays either pass
them through soft tissues like like skin
or being absorbed by harder tissues or
more dense tissues like bones the other
big use of x-rays is in airport security
so if you've ever been on a plane before
you'll know that your bags go through
you have to put them on the little
conveyor belt and they go through a
particular scanner and that scanner uses
x-rays so let's imagine that someone's
suitcase there now it works in exactly
the same way as before as these these
x-ray images here so again it's all
about using x-rays that can pass through
less dense materials or materials of a
lower density but let's say if there was
something of a higher density in there
let's say someone had a weapon you could
see what was inside because the hub of
the objects with higher density absorbs
some of those x-ray to absorb those
x-rays to create that kind of whiter
lighter section so then you can clearly
see the kind of objects and the shapes
of the objects that are in the in the
suitcase what can then happen is they
can double-check the bag they open it up
and they check what's inside to make
sure that it's safe so this is a way to
keep people safe airports meaning that
people can't bring substances onto
planes that they shouldn't have now if
we have a look at where x-rays x-rays
are in the electromagnetic spectrum we
can see there right up this end here and
this means that they are potentially
quite dangerous they're an example of
ionizing radiation the higher the
frequency the more energy which is
transferred by them by these by these
waves now because of this if you're
constantly being exposed to
x-rays then it can actually it can cause
cancer it can ionize your cells and it
can cause cancer another video explains
how that works now this is why
radiographers when they're taking an
x-ray the person doing the x-ray they
actually leave the room when you're
having it done because if they were
constantly being exposed to her x-rays
then they could potentially have much
higher risk of getting cancer now this
doesn't mean if you just have one x-ray
doesn't mean you're gonna get cancer but
if you're constantly being exposed to
x-rays it would must massively increase
your chance of getting cancer okay so
that guys is basically x-rays thank you